[Music]
you are so skinny I lost it I lost a lot
of weight how much weight did you lose
I lost 90 pounds yes I have I've lost
weight I've lost 90 pounds before right
but the last time I did it cuz I had
this premiere coming up and I wanted to
fit in this suit so I lost it in the
moment I got to 199 and 3/4 I went to
McDonald's and it had two double quarter
pounders with cheese you know because
there's like I made it I'm done
I had just gained way back so how long
do you were just ate the McDonald's for
like two days two days and but but this
time I had a child ten months ago Jack's
my baby and they gives my first baby
yeah that's crazy I'm 54 so what
happened is we're at the hospital and
someone sent a cake and so I start
eating it cuz that's what you do with
cake yeah frosting it did you work your
way inward wait you eat the frosty
thor's cake always the frosty first in
case something happens and you can't
finish it you want to make sure you get
the process if you see a cake you just
start eating the art yeah yeah yeah eat
the frosting feet the top frosting and
then the side frosting and then if
you're still hungry you can eat the
middle okay and then so I but then I
looked at my little baby there and it
just struck me that I can't do that
anymore cuz you know I mean I don't do
drugs losting all over your mouth when
you do I have done that before the night
eating you gotta be very careful but I I
can't do drugs anymore or drink and so
food was my last thing I'm a food
nobody's gonna take that away from me I
grew up in Ottumwa Iowa food I eat food
no woman no person and and and mint but
I saw that little baby and I thought you
know I got a I got a say a lot you got a
sale life that's what it is I don't say
it but that's exactly what it is yeah I
have to stay alive for a long time as
long as possible not too long you know
right but it's long as possible
he's like 54 right and Heaney I'm like
it's only dad right you know I mean
it's crazy right oh that's like a
lifelong commitment for right no are you
working out winter with your good friend
Arnold Schwarzenegger well that's the
bet you you guys hang out a lot right
well I'm not gonna want to be a skinny
guy either you know I'm still about to
you know bulk up and I've never you know
he's bulky like he said that's his say
he's the greatest bodybuilder that ever
lived right yeah but he's also your
buddy so you know he bites me to the
house at his gym it's weird it's like
it's not like a real gym it's like if
Liberace had a GM it's like a first
sight there's columns and statues and
paintings of his family and it's just a
weird vibe in there don't swardson acres
Jim has columns and it looks like a
giant like a palace yes it does it's
like this it's the size of the studio
and you go in there and he's got all his
buddies a lot of a European and they
just got g-string like they're working
out with their shirts off I swear to god
this is not it this is history it's his
happens every day over there every day
he has friends come over Aaron G ropes a
got a brawl four giant guy in there he
did ug streets are they where the real
short short underwear yeah yeah that's
all they do because then they look at
each other and then they're doing this
and so I'm there and I'm pretty good at
working out you know by myself but then
you know it's so intimidating and he'll
go who's what's Arnold doing wait
doesn't your calves look fantastic and
then he insults me like you always say
one nice thing like you feel good and
then he's like but in a good way he's
healthy wants to fix me what are you
talking about so he looked you got you
count a stick out your face is all
skinny exactly
he jams his figure is that his big me
figure he jams it into your he if he was
here he Jam his finger into your he
wouldn't touch me when I think Ayres is
the thing so so wait a minute so I'm
just trying to picture this image yeah
your this is insanity you're in a gym
that looks like a crazy fantasy world
men named Ralph and G straya
Schwarzenegger insulted you yes you look
like you could do yeah yeah yeah yeah
you're Arnold impression there are no
word I know mine at least is something
goes he's just going goggles Oh Susan he
means well he means well but it's so
intimidated by him just looking at you
when you're working out you feel very
insecure yeah because he's like the
greatest worker I have all tried and
then you're they're doing like
Jazzercise yeah it's humiliating